estamos en la última sección de este
examen número 6 en la sección número 9
que por cierto está la página 743 así
que manos a la obra pongámonos todas las
pilas el primer problema el primer
problema o no este uno no me gusta el
primer problema dice lo siguiente para
cuál de los siguientes valores de m se
cumple que 3m -1 es más grande que 10
que 3m -1 esto es más grande que 10
bueno para que el valor de m que te
parece si de aquí despejamos a m de esta
desigualdad esto quiere decir que 3 m es
más grande que 11 si sumo uno de ambos
lados de esta desigualdad y si ahora
divido entre 3 ambos lados de
desigualdad me va a quedar que m es más
grande y la desigualdad se conserva
porque el 3 es positivo
recuerda que eso es muy importante si el
3 es positivo la desigualdad se conserva
en es más grande que 11 sobre 3 que por
cierto esto es lo mismo que tres enteros
y dos tercios que tres enteros dos
tercios y si te das cuenta el inciso a
dice 44 es un número más grande que tres
enteros dos tercios es más grande que
3.6 666 y por lo tanto el inciso a es la
respuesta correcta de este problema
número uno
ok pues vamos a el problema número dos y
dice sí a por k es igual a sí a por acá
esto es igual para todos los valores de
am cuál es el valor de cam lo que me
preguntan es cuánto vale acá y bueno
este problema está muy sencillo pero ojo
lo importante es que te dicen que es
para todos los valores de a porque si a
fuera cero pues cero por lo que sea me
daría cero y en este caso se cumple pero
como es para todos los valores de amd
que te parece si dividido de este lado
entre a y de este lado de la ecuación
entre
y me va a quedar que es todo se van a ir
y acá es lo mismo que entre a lo cual es
uno y tiene toda la lógica del mundo e
inclusive puedes entrar en la parte de
atrás de este problema porque aquí el
número que cumple que cuando lo
multiplicamos por otro número es el otro
número es el 1 el 1 es el neutro
multiplicativo y ya está entonces esta
es la respuesta a este problema que por
cierto es el inciso de de igual a 1
ok problema número uno número dos vamos
al problema número tres porque éstos
están bastante sencillos problema número
tres y cambiamos al color amarillo dice
yo tengo la figura siguiente así que
vamos a hacerla
tengo dos líneas paralelas tengo una
línea por aquí cuatro líneas por acá
son paralelas y además se cumple que
tengo otra recta por acá otra recta por
acá y después por acá tengo otra recta
parecida
es algo más o menos así muy bien y
además ves el que este ángulo se llama x
x grados este ángulo se llama james de
grados y este ángulo se llama z grados y
no sólo eso me dicen que estas dos
rectas son paralelas esta es la recta l
esta es la recta m
y además me dicen que x valen 80 grados
es decir que estos son 80 grados
llévales 70 grados lleva de 70 grados y
lo que me preguntan es cuánto vale z y
ese problema está muy fácil si nosotros
nos damos cuenta que estas dos rectas
son paralelas y además nos damos cuenta
de los ángulos opuestos suplementarios
correspondientes etcétera porque porque
yo sé que este ángulo este de aquí es
exactamente lo mismo a este ángulo de
aquí estos dos ángulos son iguales
porque son ángulos opuestos y por lo
tanto si éste mide 80 grados entonces
este también va a medir 80 grados ahora
de igual manera para éste
y este ángulo son iguales porque son
ángulos opuestos y por lo tanto este
ángulo mide 70 grados y de aquí ya
podríamos obtener el valor de z porque
estos tres ángulos están adentro de un
mismo triángulo es decir que se está
grados más 80 grados más 70 grados
tienen que ser igual a los ángulos que
tiene un triángulo que son 180 grados
180 grados o dicho de otra manera se
está grados más a 80 más 70 y 150 150
grados es igual a 180 grados y de aquí
si de estos 150 de ambos lados de esta
igualdad voy a obtener que z es igual a
30 grados y ya está
de aquí puedo tener el valor de zeta
ceta tiene que valer 30 grados porque
están adentro de este triángulo ahora
también podremos fijarnos en las rectas
paralelas y decir este ángulo es igual a
este ángulo que por cierto es
exactamente igual que este ángulo y si
la recta saldría sería igual que este
ángulo por lo tanto este ángulo vale 80
grados
esto por una parte este es igual a este
ok ahora por otra parte este ángulo es
igual a este ángulo que por cierto es
igual a este ángulo porque las rectas
son paralelas y entonces estaríamos
hablando de ángulos correspondientes y
éste tendría valor de 70 grados y si te
das cuenta aquí tengo tres ángulos
suplementarios es decir la suma de ellos
me daría 180 grados y de igual manera
podremos obtener el valor de z 80 grados
más z grados más 70 grados que es justo
lo que vemos acá abajo me tendrá que dar
180 grados
bueno problemas que tienen que ver con
cazar ángulos también muy sencillo así
que vamos al problema número 4 problema
número 4 dice la ruta escénica que sigue
blanca de su casa la oficina es de 5
kilómetros más larga que la ruta directa
es decir hay una ruta muy bonita que
sigue blanca de su caso la oficina pero
este es 5 kilómetros más larga que la
ruta directa así que vamos a apuntar lo
voy a bautizar como a la ruta escénica
es exactamente lo mismo que la ruta
directa pero a esto le voy a aumentar 5
kilómetros la ruta escénica es
exactamente igual a la ruta directa más
5 km es decir es 5 kilómetros más larga
que la ruta directa y blanca llega al
trabajo por la ruta escénica y se
regresa por la ruta directa el recorrido
tiene una longitud de 35 kilómetros eso
también es muy importante quiere decir
que la ruta directa la ruta directa más
la ruta escénica se va primero por la
ruta escénica y después se regresa por
la ruta directa pues la suma de estas
dos tiene 35 kilómetros y lo que me
preguntan es cuántos kilómetros tiene la
ruta directa cuántos kilómetros tienen
la ruta directa ahora lo que se puede
hacer es tomar esta ecuación de acá
arriba y despejar de aquí
podrá pasar está del otro lado y este 5
del otro lado pero creo que lo más fácil
es pasar está del lado izquierdo de la
ecuación es decir
menos de lo que ustedes tienen restante
de ambos lados de esta igualdad esto es
igual a 5 esto por una parte y por otra
parte tengo que en más de esto es igual
a 35 ahora también aquí podría
multiplicar por menos 1 esta ecuación y
de que obtener el valor de de pero para
hacer las cosas mucho más rápidas y
mucho más entretenidas voy a sumar de
una vez estas dos ecuaciones y puede
obtener el valor de y con el valor de
emc voy a obtener después el valor de de
a ver que tengo aquí estos dos me dan 12
2 y de aquí este y éste se van porque
tiene signo contrario 12 dos veces la
ruta escénica es lo mismo que 40
kilómetros o dicho de otra manera la
ruta escénica es lo mismo que 20
kilómetros
ya tengo cuánto vale la ruta escénica
ahora yo lo que quiero es cuánto va en
la ruta directa pero ya está de una
manera muy sencilla porque si a la ruta
escénica le quitas la ruta directa te
quedan cinco kilómetros dicho de otra
manera la ruta directa debe ser 15
kilómetros o de aquí también lo puedes
intuir la ruta escénica más la ruta
directa son 35 kilómetros por lo tanto
la ruta directa debe de ser 15
kilómetros de debe de ser igual a 15
kilómetros que es la ruta directa y ya
está aquí tengo la respuesta del
problema número 4 y está bien padre
porque lo resolví usando un sistema de
ecuaciones pero bueno vamos al siguiente
problema problema número 5 el ciclo
completo de un semáforo guau esto es
también padre el ciclo completo de un
semáforo en lo que cambia de verde a
amarillo y después arrojó dura 80
segundos ok de los cuales la luz verde
tiene un tiempo de 40 segundos la luz
verde tiene un tiempo de 40
ok la luz amarilla tiene un tiempo de 10
segundos de 10 segundos y por último la
luz roja la luz roja tiene un tiempo
tiene un tiempo de 30 segundos de 30
segundos de tal manera que la suma de
estos tres la suma de estos tres que es
el ciclo completo de este semáforo son
80 segundos hasta aquí vamos bien lo que
me preguntan es lo siguiente con los
datos siguientes con estos aquí cuál es
la probabilidad de que cuando lleguemos
al semáforo no esté en luz roja
y decir que no esté en luz roja es
exactamente lo mismo que decir que esté
en luz verde en luz amarilla es decir
estos dos casos aquí yo lo que quiero es
saber cuál es la probabilidad de que
estemos en luz verde o en luz amarilla o
en los amarilla y bueno esto es
exactamente lo mismo nosotros sabemos
por probabilidad que los casos factibles
entre los casos totales y aquí tenemos
pues 40 más 10 40 segundos de la luz
verde más 10 segundos de la luz roja 10
segundos de la luz amarilla perdón y
todo esto dividido entre los casos
totales los casos totales es que el
ciclo completo dura 80 segundos entre 80
y esto es exactamente lo mismo que 50
entre 80 y de aquí yo puedo simplificar
un poco puedo quitar este serio y este 0
y me queda que la probabilidad que busco
es cinco octavos y ya está
cinco octavos es mi inciso b
inciso b y esa es la respuesta del
problema número 5 otro problema que nos
recuerda probabilidad pero que tampoco
estaba tan difícil recuerda la
probabilidad de lo que quieres unos
casos factibles entre los casos totales
muy bien hasta aquí estamos bien voy a
borrar esto vamos a poner otro nuevo pez
árbol y vamos al problema número 6 que
dice lo siguiente para cierto calentador
de agua o boiler la forma en que aumenta
el gasto del calentador es directamente
proporcional a la forma en la que
aumenta el ajuste de la temperatura del
agua a ver qué quiere decir eso esto
parece un poema esto quiere decir que
entre más temperatura tenga el agua más
vamos a gastar en el calentador es decir
más vamos a gastar décadas o más vamos a
gastar la electricidad para que el
calentador aumente la temperatura del
agua ok
dice si el gasto del calentador aumenta
en 24 pesos si yo pago 24 pesos más la
temperatura aumenta en 20 grados celsius
ok vamos a ponerlo aquí
si el calentador aumenta y estamos en el
problema número 6 el calentador aumenta
aumenta en 24 pesos en 24 pesos esto
quiere decir que a la temperatura del
agua la temperatura del agua va a
aumentar también en 20 grados
centígrados en 20 grados celsius ahora
me dicen cuánto aumentará el gasto del
calentador cuando la temperatura aumenta
a 15 grados celsius
ok realmente es un problema de razón o
de regla de tres yo lo que quiero saber
es cuánto va a aumentar el gasto del
calentador si la temperatura aumenta a
15 grados celsius y bueno pues hagamos
una regla de 3 lo que quiero saber es
esta parte de aquí y para esto lo que
voy a hacer es tomarme este por este /
este vamos a ponerlo aquí me voy a tomar
este ya esto lo voy a multiplicar por
esto ya esto
entre esto una regla de tres y me va a
dar mi respuesta y cuántos esto pues 15
por 24 entre 20 esto es exactamente lo
mismo que éste tienen mitad y éste tiene
mitad y esto es lo mismo que 15 por 12
entre 10 este tri mitad este y mitad
esto es lo mismo que 15 por 6 entre 5
éste tiene quinta es de quinta es lo
mismo que 3 por 6 los cuales 18 esto es
igual a 18 es decir que vamos a gastar
18 pesos más para aumentar la
temperatura del calentador 15 grados
hechos la respuesta es que vamos a
gastar 18 pesos más y por cierto es el
inciso b
ok problema número 6 nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo